We've moved six times in the past five years,
and every move gets harder and harder
because we have more things to take.
I can't believe that I'm saying that this is our last move
because we finally bought a house.
One of the things I've always dreamt about was buying my own home,
and I can't believe that 23 am in the position to do that.
And I couldn't be more grateful
for all of you guys that are following along
this journey that I'm on.
This household. So many memories.
From the kitchen that I cook in every single day
to our bedroom that whimsy was born in,
or the kids rooms
convincing them that monsters are not hiding in their closet.
Even though I feel so emotional leaving this house,
I'm so excited to be making new memories in the home that we bought
all the way on the East Coast.
So for the last time, we had to get some breakfast bagels at shugs.
This is the place we first got bagels at when we move to Dallas,
so it truly felt nostalgic.
We got ourselves and the movers some breakfast
and came back to our closet,
packed up.
The movers packed up the majority of our stuff on our first day,
and when we woke up on the second,
lucky got the kids ready,
and I packed up the last little bits that I needed in my suitcase.
Seeing the kitchen all packed up made It feel so much more real.
After five more hours of packing,
our whole house was empty.
And it was time for us to say goodbye.
So we spent the last little bit just looking at the house
and everything that was built in it
before embarking on our new adventure.